he's Tucker Beathard we saw on our show
how long ago was that under a little
under a year okay what's happened since
you were on our show pretty much just
been on the road non-stop and and I'm
writing a bunch of new music and just
performing a bunch of places but you
you're Austin City Limits Bonnaroo
Lollapalooza stagecoach that's pretty
that's big-time stuff here yeah you got
to have opportunities playing a lot of
really cool cool festivals and whatnot
you know and a lot of like multi-genre
festivals so it was a you get nervous
not really I mean I guess this year a
lot of Palooza I was the only country
artist to be represented at Lollapalooza
so I guess it was kind of nerve-wracking
to how they tell how they accept did
they accept you yeah it was great I mean
cuz I come from a lot of like different
influences like rock influences so it's
kind of I guess an easier to swallow to
other music fans but um it was you know
just been having a lot of fun and
getting the just experience a lot of
cool things smallest venue you ever
played man we've I guess back in the day
when I was like 19 we hit the road in
the van and just kind of played anywhere
and everywhere I mean sometimes they'd
be only like five people at a
Gainesville saloon and we're on one time
we got kicked out wait for plan yeah
well I mean we were I don't I don't do
any cover songs and we were playing for
90 minutes and I guess they expected
like a bunch of dance play something
like daniil Ginn I guess I didn't
believe us and halfway through they're
like that's pretty impressive that you
do ninety minutes and no covers at age
19 yeah I mean I guess I'd rather went
over you know small percentage of people
for my own music then just get all their
like drunk attention with song I don't
wanna be a karaoke artists you know it's
kind of all about chipping away and
building the fanbase for me so favorite
cover song as what and uh I tried I
tried doing a Bob Seger's turned the
page
I got kind of put in a spot to where I
had to do it like didn't learn it like
the night before and um I don't know if
I did the song much much but uh that's a
great that's a great song yeah
I love that song but it's fun to sing
play but what's the cover song that you
go I kill that I nail that well I don't
I don't I don't ever practice summer do
on you don't sit there and go hey I'd
like to like that song I'd like to play
that song you never hear that on the
radio where you got me there's plenty of
songs and like I love and and you know I
like to sing but like I I kind of taught
myself how to play guitar so I got I
just got to learn my own songs the
country song comes on the radio
give me a country song when it comes on
you turn it up I mean pretty much
anything Eric searches is a really good
Springsteen yeah it's catchy that's the
cool one but you don't try to you
wouldn't try to cover that I mean I
don't know I mean I I feel the same way
when somebody says all you should try to
be on that show I don't want to be on
that show that I like cuz I don't want
to ruin that show so I can understand
what you say I don't want to play you
know Eric churches music because it's
Eric church's music yeah it's like he's
out you gonna do it better than anyone
cuz he's the one who made it so high
your brother is the starting quarterback
for the 49ers yeah last time you talked
to him last time let's talk to him I've
talked to him a couple days ago we're
really close so we we talked on the
phone actually went out there a couple
weeks ago to watch and play who were
they playing they played the Cardinals
he got surrounded that was that was a
rough one they uh they're they're
building obviously right now and you
know got some guys injured and they're
really young but um I really do like I
think um I think the whole program you
know John Lynch and all them are really
trying to build from the ground up and
doing it the right way you're saying all
the right things I get that no that's
not a cliche answer for me I do is there
a part of you that likes to see your
brother get roughed up a little bit as a
younger brother that if if I was playing
against them then it's it's hard to see
you know I just want what's best for him
and support him
just a bystander's nobody can question
his toughness though that is true he's a
tough
he's a trough sob he's always been like
that whether it was a backyard football
or not he was always the guy that you
want to be on you know on his team cuz
you know he's so competitive and tough
and were you like how decent were you
did he play football with you did he
allow you to play yeah we always played
on the same teams growing up and whatnot
and um I was a definitely more like
quicker oh you're so you were his
Edelman and to his Brady all right you
brought your guitar we do sing at 20:10
buddies by the way your Tennessee
Volunteers need a coach so you got to
write a song about getting a coach here
don't you you guys are terrible you guys
are terrible I mean now this is this is
obviously fictional because you beat
Alabama 2010 Tennessee we know that's
never gonna happen now that's the whole
point of this but that's the goal and
you're writing it cuz you know you're
missing your girl you're watching this
and you're trying to pull off an upset
to get your girl to like you again yeah
I mean it's pretty much like I mean I
guess the best way to sum it up is in as
long as there's like I believe in
miracles like I can change I could
believe in miracles because I'm watching
one right now Tennessee's beating
Alabama yeah you might get the girl but
now Alabama's not losing to Tennessee no
yes Fritzi I got a little song about the
valves if you guys will humor me and
Tucker can strum along and fall a couple
of verses on it which could be a new hit
so 2010 Tennessee and he all right now
what's this called ritzy this is called
pony up for Johnny G just a couple of
verses to sample what could end up being
a monster hit okay first I'll play it
it's okay all right here we go hi
hey there Johnny Gruden can you tell me
what you're doing
Oh smiles fans gotta know if we pay up
will you show hey there rocky top we
have to make it stop
let's get back a top the sec time to
pony up Johnny I think that's a hit
right there get Jon Gruden in there and
you're good to go
that's great and you write the rest of
that Tucker I sounds done me man did you
say Dom are done no duh as well it's
great to see it Congrats on all the
success and hope you have a great
Thanksgiving and we hope to have you
back again don't forget about us though
when you get too big and then on the
Country Music Award and all of us I mean
thank us if you ever get there with a
Country Music Award you want to thank us
it wouldn't have happened without the
Dan Patrick show I really do appreciate
Jessa for you know it was my brother who
was part of a country station in Arizona
and he said you just listen to this it's
got great hooks and he's the one who
turned me on to your music or I never
would have known anything about it he
said I think he would be great and then
he found out your brother was so CJ so
that's off great story great story about
Tucker thank you for joining us thanks
AB for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]